[Arabic recitation]
gives us
in this verse
a very clear
rule and a very clear set of
circumstances for us to receive his
bless
has endowed us with blessings
as he has described in
blessings that we can see and perceive.
And blessings
that are behind the scenes
that perhaps are a m multitudes
and
that many times hold
those blessings that we can see
things that don't even occur to us that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is endowed
each and every one of us.
We are born into the mercy of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
When every each and every one of us is
born into this world
in spite of our circumstances, no matter
what our individual circumstances are,
we are born enveloped in the mercy of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
how to receive those blessings.
He says,
"If you thank me, I will increase you.
And if you are ungrateful,
my punishment is a very painful one, is
a very severe one.
We understand from this that each and
every blessing that we receive we are
expected to thank Allah
and gratitude to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
it is the essence of belief in Allah in
the last day
gratitude is the epitome of belief and
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala he even refers
to the believers as the thankful
and he refers to the disbelievers in the
Quran as the ungrateful.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala tells us
if you were to attempt to enumerate
and to count the blessings of Allah you
would fall short. you'd be unable to
because as we mentioned we are born
enveloped
in an essence of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's mercy.
Now we are to be thankful
but we are finding an uphill battle with
gratitude
because as human beings the human nature
is boredom
and boredom breeds
ungratefulness.
Boredom breeds ungratefulness
because gratitude is a learned
discipline.
The human being is not naturally born
a gracious
person. The human being is not naturally
born with the gift of gratitude. This is
a learned discipline.
This is a learned honor that a person
learns to be grateful.
And learning to be grateful
hinges
on a person not taking what he has been
given for granted.
And this is something that every human
being suffers from because naturally the
human being is an ungrateful creature.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
he says,
"And if you all were to attempt to
enumerate the blessings of Allah, you
would not be able to.
YOU'D BE UNABLE TO. AND INDEED the human
being is ungrateful
and the human being is naturally by
nature transgressing.
The human being naturally goes beyond
what is allotted to him. The human being
naturally crosses his boundaries in his
binds.
The human being
naturally
is
Now notice the workings that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala uses here. He
doesn't say
[Silence]
He doesn't say the human being is, you
know, A LITTLE BIT UNGRATEFUL.
THE HUMAN being naturally pushes
the boundaries a little bit. No, that's
not what he says. He says indeed the
human being by nature is extremely
oppressive
and extremely ungrateful. That's what he
tells us subhanahu wa ta'ala about our
own nature men and women alike all human
beings.
This is the nature that we fight with.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives us
guidance. He gives us guidance of the
Quran and Sunnah so that we may learn
how to become grateful.
So that we may learn how to thank his
blessings. sub
tells us about ourselves
in verses that our prophet
said used to recite every Friday morning
for every single week for
he would recite these verses.
any
of the world.
Is it not the case that the human being
was at one point in time nothing to even
be mentioned? Not even a thought. All of
humankind, not one or two of us, all of
humanity was not even a thought.
It merely we merely existed in the
eternal knowledge of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Indeed, we have created the human being
from drops of sexual secretions from the
mother and the father.
And we gave to him
hearing and sight
in order that we may test him in this
life. We are to be tested.
And we have guided the human being.
We've given him the nature of right from
wrong. AND WE'VE GUIDED him and he thus
chooses whether he will be grateful or
ungrateful.
That's really what we are fighting
against here.
Will we be grateful or will we be
ungrateful?
And now we must learn how to be
grateful,
how to find our nature,
our ungrateful nature.
Because as we mentioned, what breeds
ungratefulness?
Boredom.
A person looks at the mercy and the
blessings of Allah that are around him
and he feels like, "Yeah, yeah, I I
understand I'm blessed and all that, but
this is the beginning
of the of the person's misguidance,
this attitude,
the idea, THE CONCEPT THAT THE HUMAN
BEING DESERVES SO MUCH MORE THAN WHAT
HE'S been given already."
And don't think that this is a new
idea or this is a new attitude or that
nations before us did not practice this.
Don't imagine that
because nations before us fell into the
same things that our nation falls into.
Our nations are not special.
They're human. And humanity by its very
nature repeats itself.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches
us that the human being by nature is
ungrateful. The human being by nature
is transgressing,
is oppressive.
And that the human being
tends towards ungratefulness,
tends to scoff at the blessings of Allah
subhanahu WA TA'ALA, TENDS TO look
around him and see only what he does not
have.
When they look at the blessings of
Allah, the human being naturally
can only see what he doesn't have,
can only SEE WHAT HE WISHES he had,
can only see what others have and cannot
see what he has. Naturally, this is how
the human being is.
The human being naturally can only see
the half
empty part of the glass.
But we learn to be grateful. How do we
learn?
Is this something that a human being
naturally stumbles on? No. We learn from
the Quran.
We learn from the sunnah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us in
the Quran how to be grateful. He teaches
us
in the sunnah how to be grateful not
just for this or THAT BUT FOR EVERYTHING
that we have
for those things that we notice and
especially those things that go
unnoticed by the human being.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches us
this gratitude because the agreement
that he has taken upon himself
that if you all thank me I shall
increase you and if you are ungrateful
know that my punishment is a very
painful one.
And so our
position
is to train our eyes not to wander and
drift
to the half empty part of the glass, but
to train our eyes to fixate on the half
full.
Our position
is to not see
and imagine
what we wish things were, but to see and
imagine what things could be if it
weren't for the blessing of a loss of
heaven.
This is a learned skill.
Nations before us have fallen, much
greater nations.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
the people of seven
in Yemen.
It was said that they had endless
gardens
of all that the person could desire
and water flowing through it and a dam
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gave them
everything that they could possibly want
or imagine.
Just gave it to them. AND HE TAUGHT THEM
TO BE THANKFUL, to be grateful,
and he gave them safety.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, not only
that, but he gave them something that is
almost unheard of even in our time
today.
that when they would travel all the way
up to Amab and cut through the
absolutely
inhospitable deserts of the Arab
Peninsula
that along their route
countless villages were set up all the
way on along their roots all the way to
Ashe
where there they did not have to even
carry bring any extra sustenance with
them.
Road stops
thousands of years ago. Who can imagine
all along their roots? It's said that
they could they could be a fool in one
village,
get on their animal and go to the next v
village by
and by the next and by the next. And so
they We're burdened with having to carry
sustenance,
having to carry provisions,
having to plan very carefully for their
travels as safe as could be imagined, as
comfortable as possible for their day.
But they got bored with this. This was
boring.
That's not fun. Who wants to be
comfortable all the time? And so they
started to ask for love with their
hearts.
They started to say
they started to scoff at these blessings
that Allah had given them.
And they started to say, "Oh Lord, I
wish that, you know, it's great that our
travels are so short and comfortable,
but I wish that you could make our
travels very distant." IMAGINE THE HUMAN
BEING IS SO prone to boredom and is so
prone to ungratefulness
that he starts wishing for pain when he
gets too much comfort. That is your
nature. That is my nature.
As we said, gratitude is a learned
discipline. And notice what we say learn
discipline.
It's not something that comes naturally
to the human being. And number two, it
is a discipline which means that by its
very nature you can practice it for 10
20 years
and if one day you stop practicing it,
it will recede. That's the nature of a
discipline.
It's not riding a bike where you
never forget
where it just comes naturally after
that. You will always fight with your
nature.
Imagine the inhospitable desert,
the dangers of the desert, and they're
praying
that Allah will make their travels
treacherous.
They are afraid that Allah will make
their travels difficult.
And so Allah did what? He gave them what
they asked for.
And he divided them up very very slowly.
The people of Sebath, they were not
destroyed all at once suddenly by some
cataclysm. No, the people of Seah were
destroyed at a snail's pace
and this in itself
is a moment of reflection for us
because Allah has already agreed with us
that if we are thankful he will increase
us and if we are ungrateful ful his
punishment is a painful one.
We today
we do not even
we it's hard for us to even connect
with people going through any kind of
difficulty in our lives today. Today,
the average American in America today,
we can't even reconceptualize
difficulty anymore.
Things that would take a time of day of
toil and chore
come to us in a moment of in the window
of 10 minutes. Today
you have water waiting for you to turn
it on. Electricity, heat, cold. It's too
hot. Would you your drink to be a
little bit cooler? Would you it to
be a little bit warmer? Here it is.
We
live in such a sophisticated comfort
that you don't have to settle with hot
or cold. You can make it 6 to 7.5°
AT ABOUT a 0.1 degree more
for your beautiful skin to be just so
comfortable to the point that we forget
what pain feels and we start to
pray for our own downfall.
Why do you think in America one of the
most popular genres is societal collapse
and zombies? We look around and we are
so comfortable. We start to fantasize
about everything falling apart
because this is too boring. We have to
manufacture our own drama. Now
it's too boring
to always be comfortable.
I want to be hungry a little bit. I want
to be uncomfortable.
I I wish I didn't have access to
medicine,
to hot water, to fire.
I wish I didn't have access TO THESE
THINGS. WOULDN'T THAT BE GREAT? HERE'S A
MOVIE about it. HERE'S AN ENTIRE SERIES
where you can fantasize about the
collapse of modernity.
Why do we do this to ourselves? Because
gratitude is a learned discipline. IT
DOESN'T COME NATURALLY.
A person learns to thank Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
If we were to have a television show or
a movie all about things being perfectly
comfortable, every single audience
member would quit watching.
If there was no problems in the show,
nobody cheating on anybody, nobody
crying, nobody in misery, nobody dies,
no fear, no anything, just everything is
going good. We will stop watching.
That's boring. We need to have drama all
the time
because as we said, boredom is what
breeds ungratefulness.
So we fantasize.
The housewife who has all that she could
want fantasizes
about all this going away. And this is
actually holding ME BACK. I WISH I was
with the name. I wish I was with that
guy. I wish I was with
Joe Schmo from high school. I should
have done that because now who am I? I
just I'm just a milk pocket. Just a mom.
This is what we learned.
The man,
he learns that
maybe actually it's your coworker.
Your coworker is who YOUR SOULMATE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN, NOT YOUR WIFE AT HOME,
NOT THE MOTHER OF YOUR CHILDREN. SHE'S
THE ONE THAT holds the keys to all of my
happiness.
And so they go about destroying every
good thing in their own life with their
own hands. And that is the greatest of
of punishment from Allah.
Not that it's taken away from you
that you yourself use your own hands to
destroy your own life. That's the
greatest of humiliation.
And that's exactly what Allah gives to
those who are of great.
We look back to our to the companions of
our prophets.
Not one of them had THIS PROBLEM. NOT
ONE OF THEM. WHY? Because the first
lesson they learned was gratitude.
We have this problem.
the problem, this phenomenon of
destroying our own lives with our own
two hands. Why?
Because we've missed this lesson
somehow.
We drama. We want to manufacture
it. When someone has something good to
say, we listen halfheartedly. But if
there is some juicy scandal of foot,
well then I'm all ears
because please I need to feel alive.
I need to watch misery. This is this is
what really jumpst starts my little
heart and see this is the danger that we
face and we can't see Allah's blessings
around us anymore. WE START TO LOOK AT
Allah's blessings in a very very
distorted manner. We start to see
Allah's blessings as punishments.
That's really the ultimate the ultimate
[Arabic recitation]